[Music]
on this monday night start the car
you don't want to waste one minute the
u.s land border finally reopens to
non-essential travelers why those coming
into canada still need that pricey pcr
test one party propping up another what
the liberal minority government is
planning to stay in power life-saving
signal the hand gesture one american
teenager used to escape her kidnapper
and the canadian connection
honoring indigenous veterans day why
they have their own day of remembrance
and the segregated canadian soldiers who
formed a black battalion young men
arrived they were towed this is not your
war it's a white man's war
they were turned away the racism they
faced and the long overdue apology
they're getting
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
182 days yeah we're we're really ready
they are on the road again the u.s has
reopened the land border to fully
vaccinated travelers and the lineup
started early quickly becoming hours
long at some border crossings like this
one the douglas crossing south of
vancouver this morning
good evening and thanks for joining us
it's the first time in 20 months that
the border is open to non-essential
travelers businesses on both sides that
have struggled without tourism dollars
have been eager for the restrictions to
ease but it's not completely business as
usual those entering canada still need a
negative pcr test even if you go to the
states on just a day trip michael
couture has our top story tonight
the lineup of cars and rvs started early
as eager travelers queued up to cross
into the united states after a nearly
two-year wait 30 minutes at the border
felt like nothing we're just happy to
get the other side here i can see your
passenger has her documentation ready
you guys are right ready that's right
that's right we don't want to waste one
minute
that proof of vaccination is needed to
get into the u.s to get back to canada
travelers need a pcr test snowbirds
flocking south aren't thinking about
tests yet but it's top of mind for this
group of cross-border politicians we
will see significant uptick in economic
activity but we're still doing it with
one hand tied behind her back with this
redundant unnecessary testing
requirement a molecular pcr test must be
taken within 72 hours of return to
canada and can cost more than two
hundred dollars a significant expense
for families some say those tests have
shortcomings especially for shorter
trips the current system would allow
someone to take a pcr test in canada
cross into detroit to cheer on the lions
with 65 000 other fans in the stadium
and then return to canada using the test
they took before leaving asked about
scrapping the pcr test to enter canada
the public safety minister says the
government is relying on the advice of
public health officials those measures
have been very effective at managing the
risk of the spread of the virus at the
border
should that advice change we will accept
that advice when it comes friday
canada's top doctor said officials are
looking at the pcr test policy but this
epidemiologist believes testing should
remain in place especially since a large
segment of our population remains
vulnerable there certainly is the
opportunity among millions still of
unvaccinated people for significant
spread until we get those 5 to 11
children vaccinated and when there's
enough vaccination coverage in canada
the hope is that pcr test will no longer
be necessary when coming into this
country
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
the prime minister and liberal mps are
getting back to work ahead of parliament
convening on november 22nd justin
trudeau held the first full liberal
caucus meeting since being re-elected in
september and because he's leading a
minority government again he will need
to build bridges to other parties david
aiken looks at how that's going and
what's shaping up for the next session
of parliament
gosh it's good to see you guys it was
the first time in nearly 18 months that
these liberal mps had met in person and
they returned to learn about a potential
liberal ndp deal to provide some
stability to this parliament it might
involve an ndp promise to prop up the
liberals in exchange for a legislative
agenda that includes some ndp priorities
we're committed to make this parliament
work and having constructive
conversations and we're doing that with
all parties the chairperson of the ndp
caucus said much the same we have always
said that we will work with all the
different parties we're here to get the
job done though jenny kwan says there is
no formal deal so contrary to the rumor
mill that is out there just that to let
you know that there are no agreements of
any sort but that did not stop the
conservative leader from taking aim at
what he called a radical coalition
canadians can't afford this coalition
the liberal ndp coalition would be a
disaster for the canadian economy
but aaron o'toole was under fire himself
after some conservative mps voiced
concerns about vaccine mandates and even
suggested vaccines may not be safe or
effective the conservatives are actually
moving backwards more and more
conservatives are now stepping up to
stand against vaccination to stand
against science
o'toole conceded such comments were not
helpful but he said he'd deal with those
mps internally and those conversations
as you know will be
will be confidential that's what a team
does now the liberals in the ndp want to
make climate change and reconciliation
top issues this fall but all parties
agree that the most important thing on
the parliamentary docket is doing
whatever it takes to deal with the
continuing public health threat of covet
19. donna okay david aiken in ottawa
thank you the number of people seeking
to join a class action lawsuit against
the military for misconduct is
continuing to rise the deadline to join
is weeks away and what started as a few
thousand claimants has ballooned to more
than thirteen thousand abigail beeman
explains why the number is rising and
what happens next
it's very emotional first of all sam
samplonius and the group it's not just
700 are helping those who suffered
military misconduct navigate the class
action claims process and ptsd can make
that more difficult it causes a lot of
anxiety
so for some people they've been putting
it off and putting it off and now of
course with the deadline looming is for
november 24th there's a lot of people
that are going well okay i guess i don't
have any choices if i'm going to do it i
need to do it she's not surprised to see
a boost in applications ahead of the
deadline the class action opened to
claims in may of twenty twenty by
december of that year there were nearly
three thousand we last checked in in
july when they spiked to well over seven
thousand four months later there are now
more than thirteen thousand six hundred
claims and counting there's more than
enough time that they should feel really
free and welcome to reach out to us so
we can help them as best we can andrea
streetis is one of a dozen lawyers
across the country representing class
action members he wants people to know
the process is confidential independent
and the class action includes a wide
range of sexual misconduct and gender
discrimination eligible for compensation
there's a presumption that when class
members make their claim that their
claims are in good faith and that
they're honest so class members don't
need to worry about people questioning
them about what happened or
or
or doubting what they're putting forward
even with an increased number of
applicants he says there's no indication
there will be an issue running out of
money the settlement stands at 900
million dollars global news asked the
defense minister whether she's
considering raising the cap or extending
the deadline anita anand declined to
speak on camera her office sent a
statement saying the settlement was
approved by all parties and the federal
court of canada abigail beeman global
news ottawa
the u.n climate conference is still
going on in glasgow and this final week
is when the details of what countries
will actually do get hammered out today
former u.s president barack obama said
the world has to close the gap between
what's necessary for our survival and
what's politically possible
most nations have failed to be as
ambitious as they need to be
the escalation the ratcheting up of
ambition that we anticipated in paris
six years ago
has not been uniformly realized
this summit like the ones before is
being dismissed by some as more talk
than action and there are tensions
between poorer countries and wealthier
ones poorer countries see it as critical
that compensation for loss and damage
from climate change be part of
negotiations this week because richer
countries are responsible for the bulk
of greenhouse gas emissions redmond
shannon reports on the tough
negotiations underway
a mostly warm glasgow welcome for the
man who led the free world when the 2015
paris agreement was struck
but the cold hard fact is
we will not have more ambitious climate
plans
coming out of governments
unless governments
feel some
pressure from voters activists however
skeptical about how the words of barack
obama stack up against his climate
record i definitely think that president
obama is a disappointment because he
lauded himself as the black president
who cared about the people of color but
if he did he wouldn't have
failed us that conflict of the rich
world versus the poor lies at the heart
of the tough negotiations inside the
back rooms of cop 26 this week what has
been said at the higher levels
of commitment by our colleagues in the
g20s and the developed countries
are far different from what is happening
in the negotiations rooms
developing nations want more money from
funds already pledged to help them adapt
to climate change and a new fund to
compensate them for loss and damage
suffered in weather events blamed on
historical emissions coming mostly from
the west
finally nailing down the details on
carbon trading is also seen as crucial
good rules um governing countries carbon
trading would have a really strong
impact on setting good rules for the
private sector and conversely bad rules
could really
exacerbate dodgy offsets that don't do
anything to actually deal with the
mission instructions no deal would be
better than a bad deal because a bad
deal could actually undermine the entire
integrity of the paris agreement
ratcheting up emissions targets will
also be key for cop26 to be a success
any final deal will need far more detail
than paris getting almost 200 countries
to agree on those details will be just
as difficult as it sounds redmond
shannon global news london
the un world food program is warning the
number of people on the brink of famine
has jumped to 45 million in 43 countries
that is a 66 percent increase over 2019.
the organization says covet 19 plus
climate change and conflict are driving
up the numbers in afghanistan the food
crisis is deepening under the taliban
rising fuel costs and soaring food
prices are forcing families to make
devastating choices there are reports
some are so desperate they're prepared
to sell their own children
more than half the people in afghanistan
are likely to be without food this
winter unless donors step up
almost 23 million people are marching
towards starvation 8.7 million on
famine's door 95 of the people don't
have enough food it's a crisis it's a
catastrophe
the un says food prices hit a 10-year
high this month the cost of averting
famine globally now stands at nearly
nine billion dollars
coming up the lawsuits filed after the
tragedy at astroworld plus the rare
storm that struck vancouver
a number of lawsuits have been filed
after that texas music festival which
ended in a deadly crush of people eight
people including two teenagers died when
the crowd surged towards the stage at
the astroworld festival crushing those
up front rappers travis scott and drake
are being accused of inciting the crowd
and festival promoters are accused of
gross negligence for failing to
implement proper security and emergency
response measures
a missing north carolina teenager is
safe tonight after using hand signals
that went viral on tick tock to show she
was in distress the 16 year old went
missing last tuesday
police say she flashed this discreet
gesture to passing motorists trying to
signal she needed help it worked police
were called and a 61-year-old man was
arrested the signal was created during
the pandemic by the canadian women's
foundation as a safe way for those at
risk to reach out
people were being perhaps trapped with
their abusers and they were also at the
same time perhaps using video calls more
often so those two things together
seemed like a good moment for us to
release a tool that might help some
people s some of the time and of course
it's just a simple hand signal that you
can make with one hand it doesn't leave
a digital trace it means please check in
with me safely i need somebody to reach
out
the driver has been charged with
unlawful imprisonment and possession of
a minor in a sexual matter
consumers and climate change ahead how
shopping habits impact emissions
[Music]
environment canada has now confirmed it
was a tornado that touched down in
vancouver on saturday it had an
estimated wind speed of between 90 and
110 kilometers an hour and tore up trees
and utility poles around the campus of
the university of british columbia a
tornado watch had been issued after this
huge waterspout was spotted just off the
coast tornadoes are extremely rare in
vancouver
while for many consumers today making
choices about what to buy is not only
about getting value for money our
shopping habits can also have an impact
on the planet all the problems with
international supply chains have exposed
how dependent the world has become on
getting things that are produced
thousands of kilometers away tonight
eric sorensen looks at the impact that
flow of goods has on emissions
a global shortage of microchips has hit
the stalantis auto plant in windsor hard
shutting down shifts more than once it's
not alone the pandemic has sparked the
worst crisis in supply chains the world
has seen from cars to clothes to toys
container ships are stacked up at ports
there aren't enough drivers to transport
goods and widespread shortages will hit
shoppers this christmas
climate researchers say it's about time
supply chains are in the economic
spotlight because so much of what the
globalized economy produces contributes
to greenhouse gases about 90 to 95
of their emissions
meaning that their total emissions is
actually coming from their supply chain
in short the carbon from your car isn't
limited to what comes out of the
tailpipe
it starts with the mining of raw
materials from all over the world steel
and plastics to lithium and cobalt the
materials are shipped the cars are
manufactured parts are made and
transported the workers commute to
plants and more shipping to car
dealerships that use energy then you
drive the car off the lot burning fossil
fuels and eventually a car must be
disposed of every link in the supply
chain expands the carbon footprint and
affects climate many of the industry
players many of the the buyers of
materials are starting to to do those
accounts and think about well what is
that footprint and what is the total
carbon that adds up canada a major
trading nation is deeply interwoven with
supply chains not just what comes here
but businesses that export oil lumber
food as well as finished products most
of their climate impact is coming from
the
supply chain
in both directions a first step says
mit's john sturman is for companies to
accurately report their emissions
critics say some are greenwashing not
really accounting for carbon impacts up
and down the supply chain and customers
are none the wiser you don't know how it
got here but somehow another it showed
up on my doorstep and i'm happy one
response is to buy local but consumers
can also ask more questions you know
where their products come from
and what is the impact of those products
the pandemic has heightened awareness of
our precarious globalized economy but
it's an awareness that is putting supply
chains under long overdue scrutiny for
their contributions to climate change
eric sorensen global news toronto
remembering the black battalion next
what the only segregated military unit
in canadian history endured
canadian flags that were raised to full
mast at sunset last night were lowered
at sunrise today on federal buildings in
honor of indigenous veterans day they'll
go up again at sunset and then be
lowered to half-mast for remembrance day
on november 11th this day november 8th
has been indigenous veterans day since
1994. it's estimated about 12 000 first
nations inuit and metis people served in
the two world wars and at least 500 lost
their lives yet most of them were not
considered canadian citizens until after
the second world war and indigenous
people did not get the right to vote
until 1960.
[Music]
ceremonies were held in communities
across canada there are more than 2500
indigenous men and women serving in the
armed forces now and though they get the
same rights and benefits now it hasn't
always been the case until 1951 they
weren't allowed to honor lost comrades
at legions and until the mid-1990s they
weren't allowed to lay a wreath at the
national war memorial in ottawa on
november 11th
a lot of those folks didn't just
sacrifice their lives they sacrificed
their identities as status indians when
they came home they were enfranchised
and
no longer were recognized as status
indians they weren't provided the same
treatment as other veterans so creating
a day to acknowledge that is very
important
there is a long history of racism in the
canadian armed forces during the first
world war hundreds of black canadians
eager to enlist were turned away told it
was a white man's war they formed the
first and only all-black battalion in
the canadian military ross lord explains
what the segregated unit did and why a
long overdue apology is being planned
you know according to historical records
on that day it was a damp
rainy cold day and a cold shoulder for
the 600 black soldiers who sailed from
halifax harbor in 1917 sharing the
voyage to england with white troops and
here they're going into something they
don't really know what they're facing
with people who don't want them
the men felt the sting of racism every
day but especially after trying to
enlist in the war effort when the black
young men arrived they were told this is
not your war it's a white man's war
they were turned away eventually they
formed the number two construction
battalion known as the black battalion
the only segregated military unit in
canadian history as it turned out they
did play a crucial part in the war
building rail lines trenches and bridges
for the soldiers they wanted to fight
alongside when you look at the
remarkable aspect of those men wanting
to serve when they really weren't
wanted you know
as we commonly say here you know they
had to fight for the right to fight
that took a lot of inner strength for
decades their unique story was forgotten
but advocates and descendants mounted
their own determined effort first
dignifying derelict grave markers then
for a wider acknowledgement of their
ancestors and the racism they
encountered
the federal government is now planning a
public apology for next july that
apology needs to be one of those times
when folks from across the country folks
from the u.s folks from the west indies
can all come together to celebrate the
number two construction battalion and
that's part of what makes it a
meaningful apology we've developed a
website that
features a list of all of the men that
enlist it that individuals can
search from across canada and say look
you know
is there anyone in my my family lineage
that's been a part of the number two
organizers are pursuing other forms of
acknowledgement like scholarships and
including the black battalion in school
history classes
making their courageous struggle part of
canada's shared narrative
ross lord global news halifax
global news will have live coverage of
the remembrance day ceremony in ottawa
you can watch it at 10 30 a.m eastern 7
30 pacific we'll also be streaming it on
our website
globalnews.ca
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is a beautiful fall day in park
lafontaine montreal we'd love to see
your canada please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you